[Musica]
Eccoci qua Buongiorno a tutti Maurizio
Galimberti probabilmente mi conoscete
per Polaroid sono un ex geometra
diventato artista fotografo e la mia
storia tra le altre cose È un artista se
non viola il copyright oggi non può più
fare l'artista quindi si potrebbe
parlare per ore però diciamo che
partendo dalla mia storia
proprio oggi alla festa della mamma Io
ho avuto due mamme perché appunto una mi
ha lasciato al cosiddetto brefatrofio
perché era quel posto dove venivano
Lasciati i bambini con i genitori che si
sapeva chi erano maggiormente
profanartrofi sono i posti dove i
bambini erano i genitori morti e quindi
prefatrofio di Como dal 1956 quando sono
nato al 62 mia mamma era scappata dal
bagno appena partorito quindi
una vita un po' del cavolo all'inizio
sempre al buio mangiare schifoso ci
cambia abbiamo mai vestiti sempre
sporchi e quindi una vita grama Come si
dice in gergo poi nel 62 sono stato
adottato da questi Galimberti mio vero
nome bregaglio Maurizio bregaglio quindi
nagi perché mio papà era ungherese avevo
anche il suo cognome per l'adozione e
quindi nel 62 sono stato adottato da
questo Galimberti Giorgio che era un
impresario edile quindi i cantieri
le griglie dei Cantieri sapete quando
andate sui cantieri ci sono i ponteggi
io ero già abituato a vedere il mondo
con i ponteggi perché ovviamente scusate
con le griglie perché essendo uno
spanatrofio sapete quei palazzi di fine
800 io a comodo e adesso c'è al liceo
Paolo Giovio ed era un palazzo di fine
800 Con tutte le grate di inferriate
sulle finestre quindi vedevo il mondo
attraverso queste inferriate ovviamente
vedevo il mondo a quadretti non vedevo
non una visione del mondo unica e quindi
poi quando sono andato sui cantieri e
con mio papà vedevamo il cantiere
dall'interno E guardavamo fuori c'era il
ponteggio ho sempre visto il mondo coi
ponteggi e la ciliegina sulla cui
quadretti la ciliegina sulla torta è
stata che a casa mia a un certo punto
hanno messo un mosaico di San Giorgio
che uccide il drago e quindi
altro mosaico perché era un mosaico
fatto dai
mosaicisti di Ravenna quelli che hanno
famosi musei cisti che ristrutturano
anche tutte le varie opere a mosaico che
ci sono a Ravenna quelle dei Bizantini E
quindi che dire ero abituato a vedere a
mosaico poi mio papà aveva appunto
questa impresa edile Cesare Cassina che
era un suo cliente sapete Cassina quello
dei mobili grande industriale una delle
più grandi prestigiose aziende al mondo
di mobili e salotti lui era
mi fissa con il Bauhaus con Le Corbusier
con Charlotte Rihanna e chi più ne ha
più ne metta E quindi
da lì Mi sono appassionato al Bauhaus e
quando ho cominciato a fare fotografia
non ho guardato a hocney perché hochny
faceva dei mosaici
molto lontani dalla mia fotografia lui è
cubista
bracchiano quindi Brac mentre io sono
futurista duchampano Quindi io parto da
Boccioni quando Boccioni dice imprimere
gli oggetti linee dinamiche
prolungamento dei ritmi degli oggetti
stessi per arrivare ad Auchan al nudo
che scende le scale dove attraverso una
scansione del soggetto che fermo
l'artista crea movimento Ecco questo
Diciamo che un po' la sintesi della mia
progettualità quindi ho cominciato
nell'83 ho cominciato a far Polaroid
perché non mi piaceva stare al buio
quindi non potevo stare in camera oscura
mi piaceva fotografare all'epoca c'era
solo Polaroid e quindi ho iniziato a
fare il Polaroid e Polaroid è stato che
nell'89
della storia la casualità quindi vengo
preso da una famiglia di uno che mi fa
vedere il mondo a quadretti poi c'è una
pozzanghera a Vicenza c'è una bellissima
mostra di fotografia di Maurizio
Galimberti che si chiama Polaroid sx70
passano c'erano meno migliori a chi
l'avbramo Saporiti che erano i due a
direttori artista di Polaroid Italia e
attraverso una lunga pozzanghera in
Corso Palladio e per cioè fanno tutto il
porticato per non fare questa
pozzanghera e quando finisce la
pozzanghera attraversano Corso Palladio
e di fronte a loro trovano la mia mostra
quindi entrano E da lì è iniziata la mia
collaborazione con Polaroid
collaborazione che poi è iniziata nel 93
Perché a un certo punto il direttore di
Polaroid mi ha chiamato nel dicembre del
91 dicendomi Guarda Maurizio che abbiamo
un sacco di fax di fotografi che dicono
che il nostro fotografo Ambassador in
effetti è un geometra Ci sono anche le
foto di me che con la macchina dell'i
edile con il cartello a nome
dell'impresa quindi dicevo cambi o cambi
registro Quindi o vieni a fare il
fotografo da noi o sennò ti dirò
salutare io ero proprio impallinato con
la fotografia era proprio la mia vita e
quindi decisi di abbandonare la
L'azienda nel primo gennaio del 92 a 35
anni e mezzo decisi di appunto
intraprendere la carriera di fotografo
con le Polaroid e quello che mi fece
capire davvero che potevo farcela Andai
da un altro che si chiamava MG che era
Mario Giacomelli che magari c'è qualche
appassionato di fotografia lo conosce e
Mario Giacomelli mi così mi fece capire
che lui faceva quelle fotografie lì
straordinario fotografo italiano l'unico
conosciuto in veramente in tutto il
mondo degli italiani con una macchina
fotografica del 54 teneva tenuta assieme
con il nastro adesivo Quindi io
sicuramente potevo andare avanti a fare
il mio lavoro solo con le polaroidi
Infatti andare a casa Avevo delle Nikon
avevo delle Canon Vendetti tutto
e vissi felici e contento con la mia
Polaroid di plastica
poi Diciamo che la mia grande fortuna è
stata quella che con Polaroid come
Ambassador andavamo alla mostra del
cinema di Venezia a partire dal 96 dove
fotografare un sacco di attori e attrici
e nel prima la mia storia era già
diventata importante perché nel 92 feci
la fotografia della Vucciria che tra un
po' vediamo e questa fotografia della
Vucciria la feci con diciamo gli auspici
gli auguri di lino capoleccola qua
quindi raccontare un mondo nell'essenza
togliendo tutta la fisicità pensate alla
Vucciria di Guttuso E questa qui è La
Vucciria di Galimberti quindi una
Vucciria che è toglie tutto il
superficiale e va dentro nella nel
sangue della scena e proprio Lino
capolicchio e grande attore che aveva
fatto il giardino dei Finzi Contini di
De Sica e Vittorio Gassman che erano a
casa di Ignazio buttista questo grande
poeta siciliano che recitava le poesie
in piazza
altro i padroni che sfruttavano i
lavoratori mi dissero per essere per
raccontare La Vucciria deve essere
analitico ed essenziale in questa
analisi d'essenza ci sarà la tua
immagine Così fu Quindi anche i miei
ritratti diventarono sempre analitici ed
essenziali togliendo proprio le parti
superflue e quindi nel 2003 feci il
ritratto di Johnny Depp Ed ebbe un
successo incredibile ritratto di Johnny
Depp è stato sicuramente la fotografia
più importante che ho fatto perché mi ha
permesso di
permesso di essere conosciuto in tutto
il mondo perché in Inghilterra finì
sulla copertina del Times di Londra
addirittura ero così contento Quella
sera lì che feci una torta era un lunedì
e fece una torta e Andai al ristorante
dove andavo di solito Peccato che il
ristorante era chiuso quindi non c'era
nessuno non ha mai ci era stata torta
con la candelina e quindi come prima
copertina importante della mia vita e
quindi feci
quindi questo per dire che la fotografia
davvero per me è stata qualcosa di
importante come importante ad esempio
capire capire che la fotografia ha
bisogno di solitudine la fotografia ha
bisogno di solitudine perché come faceva
Picasso la fotografia bisogna sempre di
qualcosa per sorprenderti per spiazzarti
per disorientarsi e quindi tu devi
essere un po' da solo devi essere la
persona che sente l'odore del mondo e lo
racconta ma con l'imperfezione non con
la perfezione le mie Polaroid sono
assolutamente imperfette Se uno le
guarda ci sono anche delle macchie a
volte
sono anche diciamo un po' sbiadite Ma
chi se ne frega cioè la vite perfetta no
E allora perché la fotografia deve
essere perfetta punto di domanda quindi
all'interno Grazie
Grazie all'interno di un di un ritmo
vedete come qui c'è George Clooney sono
io che fotografo luna e vedete come io
vado addosso alla persona e quindi la
persona non può prendersi un
atteggiamento non può mascherarsi la
persona è esattamente fuori nel suo
silenzio interiore viene fuori la
personalità Questa è una frase
bellissima
attribuita a
un curatore francese Gianluca Nancy che
è più grande curatore che la Francia
abbia avuto e era quello che scriveva
sui ritratti di Cartier Bresson cartina
Bressan aveva lo spirito della zanzara
pungente quindi arrivava prima la porta
faceva la foto e se ne andava e quello
era suo ritratto pensate Oggi quando di
commissione Non ritratto 100.000 studi
non va bene ritratto è fatto dalla
pancia dal cuore no dallo stomaco io
stesso sono qui a parlare con la pancia
attaccata alla sedia Forse perché ho
bisogno di sentire un contatto che mi
che che la mia macchina fotografica è di
plastica sono su una serie di plastica e
questo mi diventare sicuramente bene e
più aperto a parlare a voi tra tanti
aneddoti che Posso raccontarvi
sicuramente c'è
l'imperfezione appunto che uno sto
dicendo se guardiamo Ad esempio la
fotografia di Lalla Romano che tra poco
arriva vedete quella donna che è
assolutamente
sfocata la parte centrale sfocata lei
era sofferentissima a me sembrava quasi
di fare una violenza ma però
nel dolore della vecchiaia veniva fuori
la sua personalità veniva fuori la sua
vita lei che era una donna bellissima
Eccola qui la La Romana una donna
bellissima che era stata dicono che
Cesare Pavese si è suicidato per lei e
guardate l'unghia in basso a destra che
ha la tintura di iodio perché la
sofferenza dell'arte la iscriveva con la
matita quindi cioè ed è un'immagine che
mi ha sconvolto per tanto tempo la vita
quindi la solitudine
La solitudine è proprio come come stile
di vita e
la fotografia che ti salva da questa
solitudine Poi sicuramente si può dire
tante cose ma la griglia anche la
griglia è magica e la cosa che non vi ho
detto è la musica la mia fotografia è
fatta di musica pensata Glenn Gould
quando suona le Variazioni Goldberg di
Bach Eccolo qua vedete Questo è il
Colosseo ma è dilatato non è fisicamente
il Colosseo e dilatato diventa un
cilindro quindi è la proiezione del
Colosseo lì ci sono le note musicali e
c'è dentro la mia sofferenza la mia vita
dentro in quell'immagine lì perché
Perché diciamo che la la scrittura della
fotografia è davvero un qualcosa che ti
prende la pancia e dove tu vai dentro e
vieni fuori con i tuoi sogni e che è la
tua fotografia poi quello che dicevo la
musica di Glenn Gould per me è un dogma
lui attaccato al pianoforte malato le
Variazioni Goldberg di Bach prima le
suoni in 35 minuti dopo li 51 minuti in
quei 51 minuti è lui che sta dentro la
musica e la dilata con la sua vita e con
i suoi sogni Ecco le mie fotografie sono
queste qua quindi Sognare sognare
imperfezione Non avere paura di
sbagliare perché nessuno è maestro e
assolutamente Comunque un senso estetico
che chiaramente che viaggia con un
contenuto una forma questo ci vuole però
la prima cosa che ci deve essere dietro
è l'uomo con la sua vita con la sua
sofferenza con la sua positività e
quindi non è pensabile che la fotografia
sia accademica Ecco Evviva la fotografia
in perfetta Grazie
[Applauso]